la vida le directeur de la publication
de pouce médias alors peut-être une
première réaction à ces manifestations
cet après midi vous vous en doutiez
ah oui enfin forcément on s'en doute ce
qui est ce qui est gênant effectivement
jouer quoi élargir le débat il ya le
débat sur les forces de l'ordre c'est
évident mais aujourd'hui qui est
responsable de ces manifestations qui
est responsable de cette convergence des
luttes
aujourd'hui c'est la fin finalement du
temps de l'atomisation des citoyens où
chacun regarde dans sa gamelle
aujourd'hui finalement la loi de
sécurité globale et d'autres
revendications parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses dans cette manifestation il ya
des gens qui viennent des régies les
jeunes vous l'avez dit vous l'avez
montré sur vos images olivier il ya
toute une vacation finalement vous savez
cette espèce de vieilles chimères de la
convergence des luttes et effectue
effectivement emmanuel macron et ben ça
fait deux ans et demi qui sème le vent
de la révolte
il récolte aujourd'hui la tempête
populaire avec des excès les black
blocks finalement ne sont que le
marqueur de bodo beaucoup de gens
essaient c'est très déplorable et on
pourra se poser la question si on peut
faire un petit 1 certes les forces de
l'ordre je les ai déjà dit sur votre
antenne depuis le début il ya deux ans
une solitude est jeune je n'arrive pas à
comprendre qu'on n'est pas les noms des
gens qui commettent des exactions ils
doivent être interpellés
on a eu bien fait pour les gilet jaune
pendant les grands actes donc plat soit
il ya deux choses
olivier soit emmanuel macron il est
rentré les black blocks pour finalement
de discréditer ça a été la stratégie la
théorique été mise en place pour les
jambes confinement discréditer les
revendications légitimes et si c'est ça
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est un jeu
très dangereux parce qu'à un moment
donné les forces de l'ordre on a vu des
images mais non miscibles ce policier
quels qu'ils soient qui prend cocktails
molotov nos confrères de la fp ont
montré aujourd'hui mais on va grandement
de données légers des forces de l'ordre
on pourrait imaginer qu'ils baissent des
casques parce que là ils sont ils sont
complètement pris est pris à partie dans
ce genre de manifestation et on peut
bien entendu le déplorer donc je crois
que c'est ce stratégie aujourd'hui si
c'est si tel est le cas si tel est le
cas je préside de faire entrer 500
extrémistes finalement radicaliser
radicaux pour être précis et délégitimer
les revendications
à moment donné je pense que c'est un
choix c'est une stratégie qui va
s'avérer et sincèrement redoutablement
d'un efficace et qui pourrait amener à
cette désintégration parce que le
aujourd'hui je l'avais
divers semaine dernière mais à force de
continuer à faire ça on va tribalisée la
société il y aura d'un côté les forces
de l'ordre et de l'autre côté une partie
de la population et c'est extrêmement
dangereux mais on nie absolument tous
les l'identité de la république du
centre public 1 on est en train de
détruire petit à petit la république et
moi je suis très inquiet je vous le dis
regardez les images que nous avons
actuellement à l'antenne mais c'est
catastrophique pour ce pays est en train
de déliter ce pays petit tapis à l'heure
juste